i'm devastated and extremely
disappointed by the judge's ruling
after weeks of fighting a legal battle
when i wanted to be by my little boy's
bedside
basing the judgment
on an mri test
which is the first time ever
and that he's likely to be dead
is not good enough
this is believed to be the first time
that someone has been declared likely to
be dead by an mri test
the medical opinion presented in the
call was clear
in that the whole concept of brain death
is now discredited and in any event
archie can not be reliably diagnosed as
brain dead
i feel sickened at the hospital and the
judge
have failed to take the wishes of the
family into consideration
i do not believe
archie has been given enough time from
the beginning i have always thought what
is the rush
his heart is still beating he has
gripped my hand
and there's his mother and my gut
instincts i know my son is still there
until
it's god's way i won't accept he should
go
i know of miracles when people have come
back from being blinded
this case raises the significant
significant moral legal and medical
questions
as to when a person is dead why does
this ruling today tell us
about where
society is at
we do intend on appealing this is only
the start i will not give up my fight
for my son
thank you